bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir quel gouvernement
macron de on s'attendait à une annonce
ce soir décidément le président et sa
première ministre ne sont plus à un jour
près pourquoi est-ce si long quels sont
les équilibres politiques à respecter
est ce que l'ale gauche de la macro ni
ferait pression sur les postes clés
bornes sur le terrain mais son ministre
c'est notre grand débat dans un instant
avec nos invités alerte rouge les
urgences vont craquer à bordeaux c'est
même déjà le cas faute de personnel les
admissions de nuit ont fermé notre grand
témoin ce soir vous le connaissez et
tire la sonnette d'alarmé depuis des
années milite aujourd'hui pour la
réintégration des soignants non vacciner
à l'hôpital patrick peloux est avec moi
ce soir enfin nous retrouverons nos a
franchi pour leur parti pris ce soir est
vraiment d'un gamin et son carnet de
campagne quotidien sur les législatives
brandon ouaret va revenir en archives
sur des grandes surprises des
remaniements rester dans l'histoire et
puis une petite nouvelle chloé ridel
militante engagée pour la démocratie et
l'écologie voilà pour le menu et c'est
parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs près d'un mois oui près
d'un mois après son élection emmanuel
macron n'a toujours pas de gouvernement
alors faut-il s'étonner ou même
s'inquiéter par tant de lenteur bonsoir
benjamin morel soit merci d'être là
maître de conférences en droit public à
l'université paris ii panthéon assas
bonsoir catherine tricot bienvenue
directrice des éditions de la revue
regards l amont d'un gars va bonsoir
dont les soirs si chez vous journaliste
à la rédaction de lcp en charge du pôle
exécutif et puis bon soir stéphane on
sort des fans back of qui vous ouvrait
le bal comme chaque soir à l'heure
flottement tactique anesthésie de la
campagne ou tout simplement
impréparation le diagnostic blakowski
tout de suite
[Musique]
si j'ai bien compris ce soir alors j'ai
pas compris toutes vos hypothèses mais
j'ai bien compris il y avait quand même
une chose plus importante
cet après midi que de réfléchir à la
composition de nos vertes du nouveau
gouvernement puisque elisabeth bornes
alors qu'on ne soit pas la liste des
ministres a préféré prendre ses
distances s'éloigner de paris allait
faire un petit tour aux mureaux dont les
murs rouges est pas très loin de paris
ni de matignon dès que j'ai regardé 40
km cela dit quand on a maintenant la
chance d'avoir des gyrophares des
motards mon avis c'est une demi heure
après les oraux miraumont que c'est tout
près sauf que c'est très différent de
paris numéro un taux de pauvreté qui
dépasse de 10 % la moyenne nationale
donc à rien à voir avec les beaux
quartiers où sont installés la plupart
des ministères oui alors il y avait une
dimension symbolique forcément dans ce
premier déplacement et oui quelle est la
phrase qu'on a retenue mais d'isabelle
bande jusqu'à présent c'est que elle
voulait dédier son mandat à matignon une
petite fille aux petites filles mais pas
tout le petit fils une petite fille qui
voulait aller au bout de leur rêve eh
ben c'est ce genre de jeune fille
qu'elle est allée rencontrer aux mureaux
des jeunes filles qui veulent aller au
bout de leurs rêves qui sont aidés par
des associations d'insertion pour les
femmes pour l'égalité des chances alors
qui dit que c'est un coup de com ici où
tout le monde dit que c'est un coup de
coeur mais à coups de cognac ou deux
comme ratée coup de com' réussi que
celui-ci je la trouve plutôt réussie
parce que ces jeunes filles elle était
manifestement très heureuse de voir que
la ministre leur avait réservé sa
première visite plusieurs filles ii
révèle qu'ils ont été justement impulser
et qui ont rien de ma vie de
de montrer qu'on est là et que c'est
vraiment le moment et vous êtes une très
belle représentation qu'on savait
alors pas touchant si c'est touchant
mais bon ça nous apprend rien sur le
nouveau gouvernement ouyahia notamment
kawa mais qu'est-ce que vous êtes
impatients de ses incroyables ça bon
alors je vais vous dire il ya quand même
un petit indice cac laissé filtrer il
devait de morne pendant qu'elle
discutait avec ce jeune saint louis
malle aurait il fallait commencer pas
non oui mais en fait c'est passé à tout
petit indice à buchs ag parce que vous
voulez des noms vous c'est ça et je n'ai
pas non à vous donner mais finalement
c'est dans un gouvernement garde la
parité y aura des hommes il y aura des
femmes et ben ayoub est borgne elle dit
que compte recruter un homme quand on
recrute une femme au gouvernement c'est
pas du tout le même état d'esprit écoute
chaque fois que j'ai eu à recruter des
gens voyaient qu'on a un os
sans référence à une actualité du moment
vous êtes assez surpris de voir que des
messieurs je vous dise mais j'ai
probablement aucun problème je suis
celui que vous cherchez et vous dis pas
sauté aux yeux
et puis vous avez des femmes à qui vous
devez dire on va vraiment vous êtes la
bonne personne dise non franchement il
manque beaucoup de choses voilà donc il
faut qu'on arrive à le changer
tous les goûts des ministrables qui
envoie des textos à bord dans dix ans et
moi je suis super gars grosses erreurs
là et c'est plutôt positif d'ailleurs un
pour fonder match ses déplacements oui
bah son image ça l a pas non plus une
image très très marquante à la toujours
été très discrète bosseuse on l'a jamais
vraiment vu prendre le devant de
l'estrade d'ailleurs il ya un tissu qui
est très frappant est ce que vous savez
quelle est la proportion de français qui
ne savent même pas qu elisabeth borne a
été nommé à matignon guide quoi dit deux
tiers
40 % des français sont beaucoup regardé
ces voix là ils ont des indices 1 et
jacky 10 5% wii board borgne peut-être
et la can 2% qui voit mais je connais
pas suffisamment mais c'est une femme
mon fils de sakineh
gouvernement mais c'est pas non plus un
truc qui marque alors il ya quand même
presque je dis bien presque une majorité
qui est plutôt satisfait de cette
nomination visait bien dis presque parce
qu'en fait il n'y a pas de majorité y
regarder il ya 47 % des gens qui se
trouvent plutôt satisfait mais c'est bon
on parle beaucoup moins que la barre
philippe qui lui je crois avait presque
70 % de gens qu'il y avait une bonne
opinion quand il est arrivé ce lundi
sont ceux qui la connaissent sont quand
même plutôt une bonne image d'elisabeth
board emb à créditer regarde plutôt on
attend pour un premier ministre de
l'autorité de la compétence de la
solidité bon il a aucun défaut c'est ça
abbassi les défauts de ses qualités
c'est à dire qu'elle manque un peu de
charisme puisqu'elle s'est passé un peu
c'est ce que disent les gens pas
toujours elle semble pas en tout cas
très proche de là près de 2 des français
et puis surtout est ce qu'elle sera
tenir capable de tenir tête
emmanuel macron les français pensent que
non parce que ces macro le patron tout
simplement vous qu'est ce que vous en
pensez c'était le président qui choisit
elle gouverne mal en moi je n'en sais
rien je ne suis pas un jour x positive
d'oddo je ne passe pas de coup de fil
pour me renseigner parce que en tout cas
si c'est mâcon qui décide eh ben il
n'est pas pressé le travail continue
manière sérieuse mais ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas une chose légère
elle requiert du temps des échanges de
fond et c'est ce que la première
ministre et moi même faisons donc autant
de temps qu team et que nécessaire car
il s'agit du gouvernement de la france
alors n'allez pas me dire que ma couette
en retard ce qu il a cette phrase que
j'adore personnellement je ne suis
jamais en retard parce que rien ne peut
commencer sans moi la preuve rien de
concret de lui cette rave ce qu'on lui
prête mais je trouve qu'elle peut même
aller pas mal effectivement merci merci
pour ce regard stéphane vous restez avec
nous elles za ils sont sur les nerfs les
ministres actuels un tout le monde a
fait ses cartons pourquoi c'est si long
mais justement parce qu'effectivement
alors on peut le dire avec le sourire
mais c'est difficile de composer une
équipe il ya beaucoup d' équilibre à
conserver la parité les différentes
composantes de la majorité la république
en marche le modem horizon peut être
aussi quelques noms de la droite
quelques noms de la gauche il faut
respecter aussi un équilibre peut-être
territoriale avoir un fameux effet waouh
avec un peu des surprises qu'on n'a pas
forcément eu qu'on a connu le nom de la
première ministre qui finalement était
un petit peu dont on parlait depuis
longtemps donc effectivement et puis dès
qu'on bouge peut-être quelque chose
c'est tout l'équilibré un jeu de dominos
1 il y en a un là il tombe et tout peut
s'écrouler c'est un problème benjamin
morel ce calendrier ci est tiré c'est
assez inédit quand même alors certes la
situation est inédite parce que c'est un
président hors cohabitation qui se
succède à lui même mais quand même dans
trois jours ça fera un mois qu'il a été
en effet on peut en effet penser que
emmanuel macron avait le temps de
réfléchir à ce nouveau gouvernement
alors que déjà ils réfléchissent au
premier ministre donc on peut écarter si
vous voulez un problème qui sera un
problème tout d'un coup d'urgence qui
impliquerait pour lui d'aller voir des
dossiers en réalité il ya plusieurs
éléments est un élément stratégique
parce que depuis le début du quinquennat
on n'a jamais connu autant de temps de
latence entre une présidentielle et aux
législatives si vous voulez que
justement l'effet wow porte à vous avez
besoin que cet effet wow il arrive pas
trop loin des législatives vous avez
besoin de peuple afghan prime et que
pour le coup et bien lorsque vous avez
cet effet whaou ils puissent toucher
ensuite élections donc c'est tactique
pour vous et gagne du temps pour réduire
à la période électorale ya un aspect
tactique et ensuite il ya un problème
également de banc de touche donc pour le
coup elisabeth borne est également le
symptôme c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on
voit qu'on a une macro ni qui a du mal à
trouver de nouveaux éléments qui a du
mal à trouver en fait de nouveaux
éléments de confiance et donc ça peut
poser un problème au bout d'un certain
temps un préparation selon vous
4 un tricot est ce que c'est si grave au
fond est ce que vous croyez vraiment que
les français attendent la situation du
pays est grave mais est ce qu'ils
attendent que ce gouvernement soit enfin
nommé la fumée blanche oh je crois pas
que ça se pose en ces termes mais en
tout cas ils sont frustrés d'élection
présidentielle qui a quand même été un
peu abîmée escamoté par l'entrée en
campagne si tu as he did emmanuel macron
qui a refusé de faire des débats donc on
a du coup on a on a un arrière goût
d'inachevé et sa rebelote avec
l'élection législative au tevatron parce
que les autres sur la commode à ceux qui
ont voté macro oui oui ça fait 28 % donc
on va dire que les autres ça fait
soixante combien cela semble ne pas être
plus avec 28 ans il est élu avec 50 non
non non non mais au deuxième tour mais
ya pas eu de débat au premier tour donc
il a refusé tout débat au premier tour
il a accepté un débat c'est celui avec
marine le pen c'est tout donc il ya
quand même une frustration ils rentrent
quatre semaines avant le premier tour et
il refuse tout débat et il recommence la
même chose à dire qu'en fait il essaye
de tuer le match de d'écraser tout est
pour vous pour moi évidemment préparé
oui je pense ça ne peut pas être la
préparation c'est pas parce qu'il
n'était pas au courant des dates de
l'élection législative ni même de
l'élection présidentielle donc tout ça
il le sait fort bien et moi ce que je
pense c'est que ça va lui poser un très
sérieux problème à l'avenir avec elle je
vois pas comment il va pouvoir faire les
réformes notamment celles sur les
retraites dont on sait que la population
et m'a très majoritairement hostiles
mais dans la population en particulier
les gens qui travaillent et ça n'arrive
à ambarès valeurs sont très hostiles à
cette réforme et que donc les sicav et
tous les syndicats fait donc comment
va-t-il faire s'il n'a pas porté cette
réforme s'il ne l'a pas discuter même
avec ses opposants en refusant de
discuter en ne faisant pas campagne ne
peut pas se prévoir se prévaloir pardon
d'une des gîtes imiter et de politiques
rappelant aussi et ça il faut le faut le
dire c'est la loi qui a changé ça et il
ya toute une série de vérifications de
la haute autorité pour la transparence
de la vie publique comment ça fonctionne
est ce que tout le monde doit être
vérifiée ou pavant nomination c'est de
toute façon je pense la crainte en de
tout président de la république et de
tout premier première mini c'est la
boulette on découvre rr un énorme
dossier sur un ministre comme ça a pu
arriver donc il ya des vérifications qui
peuvent être faites en amont mais ça
c'est systématique c'est pas
systématique et on sait que c'est plutôt
de l'ordre de la coulisse normalement
les vérifications sont vraiment a
posteriori mais on peut demander des
vérifications sur effectivement telle ou
telle personne on envisage d'y aller
piocher à la banque on vérifie des gens
qui nous on se dit qu'il pourrait être
nommé 5 on vérifie avant les nommer donc
on vérifie au delà de simples listes des
complices de temps qu'est ce qu'on
vérifie exactement on vérifie à la fois
le patrimoine qui n'y pas de conflit
d'intérêt que vous ayez en réalité un
profil de ministres qui correspondent
aux grandes règles qui ont été
introduites loi sapin doit sapin deux
dents aujourd'hui notre droit concernant
l'éthique publique après le problème
c'est que si vous faites vérifier un
dossier a lâché tvp et toutes les
chambres
et toutes les chances pour que sa suite
et donc à partir de là lorsque vous
faites vérifier vos ministres en règle
générale les ministres que vous envisagé
sérieusement vous faites un peu au
dernier moment ce qui est lors des
dernières nominations l'un des facteurs
de retard patent disait que ma catherine
les gars avaient été vérifiées
du château de versailles
disait puisque la haute autorité se
penche sur nbc que compenser ya aussi
dans ce temps la communication vous
montrer que et bien c'est les abeilles
baume qui doit décider maintenant est
proposé avec une liste au président ses
choix vous ils vous y croyez à ça quelle
est sa marge de ménage vous fait sourire
benjamin morel alors soulagé décident dé
ministres alors sait jamais un seul qui
décide ça y est vous avez toujours une
marge de négociations entre le premier
ministre le président la république en
période de cohabitation le premier
ministre arrive avec des noms et le
président de pau certain veto hors
période de cohabitation c'est contraire
le président donne c'est non et certains
mines est certes un premier ministre qui
ont un poids politique et bien peuvent
dire non celui là je ne peux pas
travailler avec lui non celui ci je ne
peux pas travailler avec lui celui ci
pas le même poste acceptera etc plus
vous avez d'autonomie politique que vous
avez deux forces politiques plus vous
avez trouble dans la majorité l'espèce
et vous pouvez imposer votre agenda pour
le coup elisabeth bornes aujourd'hui n'a
pas réellement troupe elle n'a pas
vraiment de sous groupes au sein du au
sein du parlement elle n'a pas non plus
elle n'apporte pas des lecteurs à
emmanuel macron donc évidemment elle est
dans une position qui n'est pas une
position de force pour négocier son
gouvernement et dont je vais très très
qu elle n'a pas non plus d'enjeu à
défendre ça je veux dire qu'elle est
franchie la partie histoire
politiquement politique oui enfin elle
est politiquement elle est quand même
assez transparente quoi sert ya eu en
tout cas c'est vrai mise en scène on
voit que la photographe officiel de
l'elysée a publié des photos des
déjeuners de travail donc on veut
vraiment montrer voilà que les deux sont
associés dans la discussion au sénat
après que son directeur de cabinet
aurélien rosso qui l'agencé régionale de
santé d'ile-de-france pour maintenant
piloté de cabinet de matignon lui a été
imposée ces tenues très bride courte si
j'ose dire depuis des idées c'était déjà
le cas pour jean castex était quelque
chose qui avait négocié edouard philippe
edouard philippe avait exigé d'avoir son
directeur de cabinet de pouvoir nommer
qu'il faut voir que la machine matin les
badauds dumas à l'époque et m matignon
c'est vraiment le coeur nucléaire du
pays c'est à dire que l'administration
est dirigé depuis matignon et l'elysée
n'est qu'une pme à côté donc si vous
contrôlez le directeur de cabinet qui
depuis 2010 est on à une ovation les
conseillers communs entre l'exil entre
l'elysée et matignon eh bien vous
contrôler directement via l'elysée ça
c'est machinalement nouveau et matignon
c'est nouveau en effet depuis le début
du quinquennat d'emmanuel macron en tout
cas depuis le gouvernement castex penser
qu'il pourrait y avoir des directeurs de
cabinet déjà prêts à être nommés ou
nommés avant même qu'un ministre n'a pas
choisi c'est assez probable c'est assez
probable que de toute façon ça fait pas
mystère que souvent le dessus qui a le
dernier mot et celui qui impose des
choses c'est emmanuel macron même si on
l'a vu qu'il avait promis une nouvelle
méthode on sait bien que voilà dans les
décisions c'est quand même un président
qui est omniprésent pas qu'on a installé
à matignon qu'on peut éventuellement
peser castex avec départ et arrivée un
peu sans rien dire et puis quand il a eu
plus de poids il a pu composer des
équipes un peu plus oui il faut d'abord
prendre ses marques une fois à
l'intérieur un mot sur elisabeth bornes
on va revoir quelques images de son
déplacement aux mureaux pour parler
égalité des chances c'est pareil on peut
choisir des mureaux ont quand même pas
comme premier déplacement de deux
campagnes alors est ce que c'est de la
campagne est ce que ces chefs de la
majorité ce que la première ministre
plus s'exprimer que la candidate en tout
cas elle dit qu'il faut aller au bout de
ses rêves
la dédie cette visite de terrain à
toutes ces femmes ces associations pour
pour l'insertion des femmes elle
voudrait même en faire une grande cause
du second quinquennat je dois tout à la
république at elle dit on la connaît pas
mais on commence à la connaître il y
avait un papier dans le point qui a
raconté son histoire personnelle qui
n'est pas banal c'est moi qu'on puisse
dire un père qui a été résistant qui a
été déportés pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale résistants juifs et puis qui
s'est suicidée bien après puisqu'il a pu
en réchapper
les pupilles de la nation
ça c'est elle en parle peu mais on le
découvre c'est pareil quand même ce cet
héritage là non et on sent bien que
effectivement il ya là une image un peu
de techno qui lui colle à la peau depuis
longtemps et on sent qu'elle a aussi
voulu peut-être raconter plus son
histoire personnelle est les pupilles de
la nation dont elle a fait un parcours
qui est vraiment lié à la méritocratie
effectivement on sent qu'elle essaye en
tout cas par petites touches d'imposer
peut-être un peu plus de dire un peu
plus qu'ils allaient de s'imposer
effectivement peut-être comme une femme
de gauche parce qu'on dit beaucoup c'est
une femme de gauche mais je suis pas sûr
que dans l'opinion publique ak
c'est comme ça qu'elle a été présentée
avec elle en est devenue un public aux
lettres tous que les français la voient
comme une femme de gauche mais en tout
cas effectivement c'est peut-être le
portrait qu'elle essaye un petit peu de
donner d'elle était très pudique ne sont
pas en parler on a dû la force et on a
déjà pu dire maintenant tu peux pas
comme ça ne rien dans un cube à quatre
entre je pense que c'est une femme qui a
une histoire personnelle certainement lé
en a d'autres et bon elle a 60 ans donc
en soixante ans de vie se passe des
choses donc qu'elle ait une vie
personnelle et voilà c'est une épaisseur
je n'en doute absolument pas le problème
ce qu'on attend c'est de savoir quelle
politique elle va mener et puis pour
l'instant celle qu'elle a menée disons
depuis qu'elle est ministre ne n'ai pas
marqué du sceau de la gauche c'est quand
même elle qui c'est assez amusant et les
candidats dans le calvados la
circonscription well well va se
présenter c'est une circonscription qui
a vu une ligne fermée à la suite des
réformes qu'elle a introduite de
privatisation d'ouverture à la
concurrence
la réforme de la sncf et donc une petite
île qui a été fermé donc bon ça fait pas
d'elle digne super écolo ni une femme
très progressiste qu'elle jeunes qui ont
profité dans le calvados du plan un
jeune un emploi qui sait ce que cette
voie là une deuxième réforme que je
trouve très intéressante c'est qu'à mon
avis d'heure et se tire une balle dans
le pied c'est qu'elle a conduit la
réforme sur le chômage l'arrêt fonctions
passionnantes sur l'assurance chômage
qui fait que les gens ont moins de
couverture de protection quand ils sont
au chômage moins longtemps il sent le
montant et la durée avantage c'est qu'il
ya moins de gens au chômage c'est là ma
grosse les yeux quand on est mieux
travailler qu'on met l'autre chômage le
consommable longtemps et qu'on vient
d'entendre ça car la réforme des
retraites et qu'on a des gens qui ont 58
ans 59 ans qui sont au chômage et qui se
disent qu il va falloir tenir jusqu'à 65
ans ben ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'ils anticipent qui vont être au rsa
quand ils vont être arrivé à la retraite
ça veut dire qu'ils vont être dans la
misère avant la retraite plus une petite
une petite retraite serre que la réforme
des retraites qu'elle va devoir conduire
et lesté de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage qu'elle a conduite elle même
alors puisque l'eau ça va très très mal
se passer en attendant il y en a un qui
occupent le terrain c'est jean luc
mélenchon va en parler dans un instant
mais pénètre benjamin morel on sait que
au sein de la macro ni il ya deux jambes
deux aile droite et gauche on a
l'impression que la droite n'a pas son
premier ministre puisque catherine
vautrin n'a pas été choisi et que
maintenant elle va essayer de peser sur
les portefeuilles clés les grandes
réformes qui parle à son électorat
évidemment le travail des affaires
sociales pour les retraites mais il ya
l'éducation aussi on s'attend à une
grosse réforme un big bang ça ça compte
beaucoup dans l' équilibre final ça peut
compter beaucoup dans l' équilibre
finale mais en réalité la question c'est
combien d'électeurs la droite at-elle
apporté avec ses réformes c'est à dire
que aujourd'hui l'électorat de droite
est bien campé par emmanuel macron il ya
plus vraiment beaucoup d'électeurs aller
chercher même en vue des législatives
à droite en revanche positionnement de
la nouvelle mais un visionnement la
nouvelle première ministre parce que dès
le moment où vous arrivez à coaliser
votre compte dans une élection
législative vous représenter une force
qui peut être menaçante or la droite ne
s'est pas coalisés la droite part en
ordre très dispersé
en revanche la gauche elle s'est
coalisée
et peut aller chercher des électeurs et
donc pour le coup il faut pour
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron camper cet
espace électoral et à accueillir une
partie de l'électorat social démocrate
pour ne pas qu'ils passent à la nuque
l'enjeu pour lui est là pour l'instant
d'où le fait que bien des réformes de
droite on verra un peu plus tard et que
la première miss se présente comme étant
de gauche un mot là-dessus oui c'est
vrai qu'on annonce le premier texte en
juillet devrait être un texte sur le
pouvoir d'achat et les députés la
république en marge de la majorité nous
disent voilà non à faire campagne là
dessus pour les élections législatives
on va pas forcément parler de la réforme
des retraites tout de suite alors je
vous le disais c'est jean luc mélenchon
qui occupe largement le terrain vous y
étiez aujourd'hui l amont d'un gars va
le leader insoumis à présenter ce qu'ils
appellent le programme partagé de la
nuque 660 propositions et quelques
nuances entre les différentes
composantes de cette coalition de gauche
présentation sous votre plume
commentaires en images est là
ils ne se quittent plus et veulent
afficher un front toujours unis les
représentants de la nuque la nouvelle
union populaire écologique et sociale
ont présenté un programme non pas comme
un cette fois les partager nous sommes
partis avec une ambition très forte
faire mieux que quelques mesures
qui auraient réduit notre union un
caractère de pure cartel électoral
mais sans avoir pour objectif en quelque
sorte une sorte de fusion de tous nos
programmes parce que nous savions que
c'était impossible ni chapitre 650
mesures dont beaucoup font l'unanimité
retraite à 60 ans en smic à 1500 euros
nets blocage des prix des produits de
première nécessité mais pas question de
terre les désaccords enfin les
partenaires de la nu préfère parler de
nuances il on dénombre 33
le nucléaire en est une sur ce point les
communistes font entendre une voix
différente
qui taraude le plus les français
aujourd'hui c'est la question des
salaires c'est la question du pouvoir
d'achat c'est la question du niveau des
prix est sûre ça nous sommes d'accord et
pour le reste sur la question du
nucléaire le parti communiste reste
convaincu qu'on a besoin de lui faire
dans le cadre d'un mix énergétique est
ce la version ne doit pas nous empêcher
d'avancer ensemble sur tous les autres
sujets qui sont très très importants sur
toutes ses nuances la nuque propose que
ce soit le parlement qui tranche autre
débat la sortie ou non de l'otan le
leader des insoumis reconnaît que sa
position n'est pas partagée
il préfère donc botter en touche c'est
le président de la république qui est de
toute façon le garant des traités et
alors on commence à sentir qu'il est
gamin les les nuances les difficultés la
650 propositions communes mal d'où c'est
c'est déjà ça paraît beaucoup moins vous
semble quoi anodin ses nuances noms ne
sont pas anodines et elles sont connues
enfin je veux dire ces différences elles
ont été assez identifié dès le soir du
premier tour quand a commencé à
s'esquisser l'idée de faire un front
commun bon c'est que sur la question de
l'europe ils disent pas exactement la
même chose sur la question de l'otan
sont nucléaire il ya d'autres sujets
comme ça qu'ils ont été listés mochot ça
plutôt pas mal d'avoir une transparence
ces derniers sont elles sont listés dire
qu'elles sont pas justes on dit pas
juste comme ça c'est ses actes et voilà
sur ce on est d'accord sur y en a 33 650
voilà où ça a quand même à des réformes
de structure oui bien sûr mais ça les
empêche pas de penser qu'ils vont
pouvoir faire beaucoup de choses
ensemble et je pense qu'ils ont plutôt
pas tort elles sont incroyables ces
images on s'habitue progressivement
avoir des gens qui sont ronds pas parler
pendant des années à faire estrade
commune alors tous les socialistes ne
sont pas mais quand même c'est lui qui
imprime son tempo la gauche là la gauche
dans son ensemble
un patron c'est mélenchon aujourd'hui
oui tout bêtement parce que les
électeurs quand vous prenez le premier
tour des présidentielles il s'est passé
quelque chose auquel les vieux appareils
ps et verts ne croyait pas l'électorat
social démocrate en tout cas ce qu'il
reste et qui n'était pas passée chez
emmanuel macron n'a pas hésité à voter
dès le premier tour jean luc mélenchon
et donc il est passé justement à une
forme d'union de gauche derrière
jean-luc mélenchon à travers une c'est
un système de vote utile donc ce faisant
et bien construire quelque chose
il est aujourd'hui divisé c'est à dire
que vous en avez une partie qui est
passé chez emmanuel macron et qui tenue
structurellement par emmanuel macron il
vous en avait une partie qui vote utile
aujourd'hui au premier tour des
présidentielles démocrate dans
l'entourage mélenchon
quand je parle de social démocrate je
parle de skhira du parti socialiste et
de la banque et de la branche des
électeurs qui sont passés chez les verts
je parle pas du tout des partis donc là
vous avez en effet aujourd'hui un espace
électoral coincer la banque il est sûr
que c'est par choisir marchés émergents
allaient olivier faure où les maires des
grandes villes les maires des grandes
villes socialistes ou les maires des
grandes villes écologistes ce sont des
figures quand même des relations
sociales démocrates si vous voulez
cesser
la relance au marxisme social et social
davantage encore par du tornos génial a
voulu soigner au marxisme la page tu
veux
c'est l'alliance entre les socialistes
et les communistes historiquement et
donc c'est quand même 7 le disant vous
écoutez jean mus en lettres capitales et
quand vous écoutez françois mitterrand
oui voila
je veux pas rentrer dans les débats et
dans les débats historiques en effet le
programme de françois mitterrand 80 est
beaucoup plus à gauche le programme de
la nubie donc là dessus il faut un peu
se calmer et pour le coup l'électorat se
moquera dû changer et que pour le fait
qu'on le met mais peut-être ou peut-être
pas mais aujourd'hui stratégiquement ça
a du sens c'est pas pour défendre ce
programme et pour le coup ça a du sens
électoralement après sur les scellés 600
propositions en fait c'est pour
crédibiliser un programme en réalité la
plupart des français ne verront pas les
170 cette proposition l'objectif c'est
de donner de la crédibilité ce qui
détermine électorat et on peut s'en
plaindre peut-être mais c'est
aujourd'hui un leadership et là c'est la
force de jean luc mélenchon le dos et
les politiques avaient exactement
électorat un espoir à travers un
leadership ça marche aujourd'hui comme
ça dans toutes les grandes démocraties
occidentales c'est lié à la
médiatisation xi et cetera ou à ça même
dans les régimes parlementaires et
ensuite quelques propositions phares
aujourd'hui il va falloir voir quelles
sont les propositions fars que la nuit
voudra mettre en avant chapeau l'artiste
mélenchon dans cette séquence
mardi son plan politique c'est
remarquable d'avoir qui répondent par
titre en expérience d'avoir corriger le
défaut de ses premières campagnes et
puis justement d'avoir jamais lâché
drain cette idée d'avoir incarné ce
changement d'avoir gommé je pense qu'il
va pas gommer mais ce qu'il l'a toujours
ce temps ce tempérament lui cette
manière de savoir un carnet
ouais donc moi j'ai trouvé ça très fort
je ne mens pas encore une fois il
voulait bien me sentais que j'étais pas
un grand grand grand fan de son
programme mais en revanche en terme de
politique ce qui peut réussir son pari
cimade les sondages aujourd'hui et ils
sont bons les sondages mais en même
temps il faut les prendre avec
précaution parce que c'est des
projections de la présidentielle c'est
pas des sondages sur les noms des
candidats
circonscription par circonscription 27%
des intentions de vote pour la nuque 26
pour le camp d' emmanuel macron 23 pour
le rassemblement national c'est un
sondage ifop pour lci à prendre avec
précaution mais ils sont portés les
nippes siens
on voyait des excuses et maquettes mais
on a envoyé juste le clan mélenchon et
la jeune génération qui l'a fait à l'est
ou au premier plan et les jeunes votent
pour lui donc c'est vous y croyez
vraiment je ne sais major je ne sais pas
s'il va y avoir une majorité à
l'assemblée nationale par contre ce que
je pense qu'il est possible c'est que la
nuque sortent en tête ou du premier tour
ce qui sera un signe politique très
important dire que si il ya plus de gens
qui votent pour le programme de la nuque
les 650 proposition que pour le
programme porté par emmanuel macron et
son et ses ensembles son ensemble je
pense que ça ne pourra pas ne pas avoir
de conséquence je ne sais pas si ça sera
dur en nombre de sièges parce que
d'autres mécanique institutionnelle qui
font que ça sera difficile probablement
pour la nuque d'avoir la majorité mais
politiquement ça ne sera pas sans
conséquence elle demande un gamin qui
joue vraiment la mobilisation en fait on
sent bien ils veulent donner envie ils
veulent dire que leur accord n'est pas
simplement un partage des
circonscriptions mais qui continue à
travailler ensemble ils veulent un peu
vendre du rêve on sait que jean luc
mélenchon pendant sa campagne il est un
peu idéaliste ça s'appelait aussi aux
gens et ils veulent absolument continuer
à mobiliser leur électorat dont de temps
en temps alors offrir voilà une photo de
famille où tout le monde va bien on joue
avec mélenchon l'a dit on mais pas on ne
cache pas la poussière sous le tapis on
a des désaccords mais on avance on est
ensemble et il veut la victoire il sait
qu'il n'aura pas forcément mais en tout
cas il sait que c'est comme ça qui peut
mobiliser son électorat le plus à mort
est extrêmement important en réalité
parce que dans une élection vous avez
une forte abstention celui qui remporte
l'élection qui fait le meilleur score
c'est pas celui qu'elle plus large
électorat c'est celui qui arrive le
mieux à mobiliser sa base électorale
code électoral quand vous avez beaucoup
d'abstention chaque électeur contre
beaucoup beaucoup plus que son poids
démographique
hélas en règle générale qu'est ce qui se
passe dans une législative classique
déperdition
alors oui et non c'est à dire que là on
a un électorat président de l'élection
présidentielle de la majorité qui se
sont mobilisés parce qu'il est content
il est persuadé qu'il va gagner mais
l'électorat de l'opposition de les
persuader qu'il a déjà perdu et donc il
reste à la maison la force de jean luc
mélenchon c'est d'avoir dit à cet
électorat vous pouvez gagner et donc
aujourd'hui quand vous prenez des
enquêtes vous avez une mobilisation de
l'électorat de gauche et ça en effet ça
change quelque peu la donne même si des
logiques institutionnelles qui dans une
période de tripoli risation de la vie
politique favorise le parti centriste et
bien défavorise profondément la nuque et
donc font penser que en effet ils
n'auront pas de majorité néanmoins
premier tour en effet une bonne à mettre
une première place
je dirais qu'avec au delà des conditions
c'est aussi les sociologique le vote on
sait les jeunes et les pauvres qu'il
fallait bon aloi dans les pauvres en
tout cas les plus modestes qui vote le
moins donc c'est évidemment ceux qui ont
sont qui veut tout puissant mélenchon on
considère que c'est ils veulent en
l'occurrence pour les plus pauvres
plutôt pour le pen c'est le gros
problème de marine le pen grève pop
seulement elle démobilise sa base
électorale mais en plus elle a une base
électorale très abstentionnistes gavage
jean luc mélenchon et la nuque aussi
leurs soucis fin plus pour la france
insoumis c'est l'implantation on voit
que jean luc mélenchon il est en tête
mais ces noms des circonscriptions qui
sont un peu tout le temps au même
endroit en fait il ya la banlieue
parisienne y aller autour des grandes
villes aussi mais c'est vrai que sur
tout le territoire on voit que
il peut pas forcément remporté
énormément de circonscription un mot à
mot c'est pour dire que je pense que les
trois les trois formations politiques
ont intérêt à cette alliance est à dire
que le parti socialiste a besoin d'être
clarification et je pense que olivier
force saisi cette salle jean luc
mélenchon pour faire cette clarification
du côté de l'écologie également on a
bien vu qu'il y avait quand même des
tensions à l'intérieur d'europe écologie
donc ça leur permet de clarifier à
l'intérieur de ces deux pôles parti
socialiste europe écologie sur des
désaccords internes qui finalement les
pénaliser et ont fait un très mauvaise
mauvaise campagne est un très mauvais
résultat jean luc mélenchon lui il tire
la baie de bénéfices de la dynamique et
de finalement il est celui qui a réuni
les gauches cette aspiration tellement
forte de l'électorat de gauche qui
demandaient cette union pour terminer je
les connaisse un petit mot de la droite
mais non non pas à prédire il tire
également un avantage qui va être un
groupe et des financements et ça ça peut
être un problème à terme pour jean luc
mélenchon parce que aujourd'hui et
demain probablement le pse ee lv le pc
auront une autonomie financière et
pourront jouer leur propre partition
dans la prochaine législature d'autant
que le ministère de l'intérieur a décidé
de donner le nom des élus par étiquette
de parti politique reconnu la nouvelle
politique en visant mme delenne fait çà
çà çà çà l'embêtent parce que le
camembert le soir des élections il va
pas être aussi lisible
que quand on est l'opposition le premier
groupe à l'assemblée s'il était le
premier gros on a énormément de pouvoir
au sein de l'assemblée regardé comme
avec 17 députés ils ont réussi à peser
sur les débats et imaginer que s'ils
sont à la tête je pas de la commission
deux pas des finances messi se
réveillent les gros prix donc la
commission vient tout petit mot sur sur
la droite en attendant la fumée blanche
peut être demain ou un début de en début
de semaine pourquoi pas le week-end on
n'en sais absolument rien prise en étau
vous disiez tout à l'heure benjamin
morel il ya plus d'électeurs de droite
ils sont touchés macron ya jean françois
copé qui a eu cette initiative est
extrêmement minoritaire mais de dire au
fond attendons les législatives et
proposons une sorte de pacte majoritaire
mais en étant l air c'est à dire pas de
des botteurs débauchages individuels
mais l air est ensemble devrait négocier
pour cueillir des ministres pour qu'on
puisse voter tout en cultivant une
différence sur le régalien par exemple
tout ça c'est compliqué de nouveautés
est impossible d'abord parce que vous
avez une partie de la base électorale
quand même de la droite qui est très
intime à crosne yen et que surtout vous
avez une base militaire de la droite qui
est très anti microbiennes et qui
parfois est plus proche de zemmour que
de macron alors que les élus et
notamment les grands élus en effet sont
plutôt mac os compatible donc c'est pas
aussi évident du point de vue des
droites et par ailleurs ces législatives
ne sont pas perdus pour l air parce que
pour le coup l'implantation locale dans
des cirques ou rurale etc peut malgré
tout faire la différence quand vous avez
un député l'arène où un candidat la raim
qui se présente et qui n'est pas du tout
implanté face à quelqu'un qui a été
maire qui a parfois été député vous
pouvez avoir une prime au sortant ça
peut fonctionner et donc sans faire en
effet un groupe majoritaire il faut pas
se leurrer et l'herbe sauver les meubles
merci beaucoup merci pour votre
expertise à chacun des
ex à 20h03 on va accueillir à présent
notre grand témoin patrick peloux alerte
vous le savez sur la situation des
urgences à l'hôpital depuis des années
on pourrait croire qu'il n'ya rien de
nouveau sous le soleil sauf que cette
fois ci on est proche de la catastrophe
des services entiers obligé de fermer la
nuit ou le week-end faute de personnel
et puis des malades qui pourraient
rester sur le carreau même en cas de
gros pépin à bordeaux à marseille les
entrées ne se font plus qu'au
compte-gouttes stéphanie des pierres ou
chu de bordeaux les urgences sont
désormais fermés au public la nuit faute
de personnel et nous manque à peu près
40% des effectifs médicaux de 20 heures
à 8 heures l'accès aux urgences sera
impossible sauf pour les patients amenés
ou envoyés par le samu pour les patients
qui n'auront pas à appeler le 15 on leur
donnera la possibilité d'appeler le gaz
à partir du hall d'entrée des urgences
et à sont là ils auront la même
évaluation que s'il avait appelé de chez
eux et c'est le même scénario un peu
partout en france à laval depuis cet
hiver les urgences sont fermés plusieurs
nuits par mois c'est parfois le samedi
parfois le dimanche parfois le jeudi
difficile de s'y retrouver
à marseille à l'hôpital de la timone les
urgentistes redoute une catastrophe
5 et pour l'été pour les deux mois à
venir le chu il n'arrive pas à trouver
suffisamment de médecins pour les gardes
de cet été avant même l'arrivée des
vacanciers il n'y a que 16 urgentistes
alors qu'il en faudrait 30 à chaque
garde ce médecin ausculte toujours plus
de patients d'avoir 30 passant par jour
en moyenne il ya un mois deux mois on
était aisément à plus de 55 cents par
jour pas remettre ça les augmentations
de salaire du ségur n'ont pas suffi les
difficultés de recrutement touche tous
les services et tous les métiers on n'a
pas su réagir pendant la vague de winne
le gouvernement à continuer à fermer
donc on arrive à avoir dégoûté beaucoup
de soignants
nombreux départs 60000 postes
d'infirmiers vacants dans les
établissements de santé actuellement
avec des des soignants qui disent que
demain sera pire parce que les plans
d'économie perdure le souci qu'on a
c'est qu'il n'y a eu aucune anticipation
nous ont dit depuis cinq ans former des
infirmières former des infirmières nous
manquons infirmières nous manquons des
soignants n'ont rien n'a été fait la
réforme de l'hôpital sera un des grands
défis du prochain ministre de la santé
pour voir patrick penaud bonsoir merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
merci à vous on savait évidemment que
les urgences étaient était à loos un peu
partout en france mais là on comprend
qu'on frôle la catastrophe
on a on a l'impression d'avoir vraiment
franchi un cap dans les tensions à
l'hôpital oui et puis il faut arrêter de
dire qu'on va dans le mur ou qu'on va à
la catastrophe nous y sommes
nous y sommes on gère une situation de
crise tous les jours dans le silence le
plus total mais le silence est rompu
parce qu'une digue a été franchie dans
le code de santé publique vous pouvez
pas fermer un service d'urgence
dans le code de santé publique une loi
avait été passé du temps du quinquennat
de françois hollande disant que toute
personne doit être à moins de 30 minutes
de services d'urgence
même l'état vient de rompre cette parole
sacrée de la loi ce qui fait que là on a
plus de personnel ce que me disent les
collègues est exact si vous prenez par
exemple l'exemple de la timone j'étais
allé soutenir un combat marseille un
combat que menait notamment des
urgentistes des femmes qui était
remarquable elles ont démissionné elles
sont parties d'accord il ya des services
d'urgence même à à deux pas d'ici à
l'hôpital necker onze démissions de
temps plein vous traversez vous avez une
vision sur la gare peu près même plus
que l'ap-hp au niveau national vous avez
à peu près une centaine de services
d'urgence qui ferment leurs portes la
nuit je sais pas alors je sais très bien
comment ça va se jouer le jour on va
avoir un mort devant un service
d'urgences fermées la nuit alors là vous
allez voir la une de tous les journaux
et tout le monde va s'affoler quand on
fait ce qu'on appelle le filtrage c'est
officiellement le mot qui est employé
c'est à dire par le 15 le samu pas fait
on entre malgré tout faut pas dire ça
faut pas faire ça nous mettons un filtre
nous mettons une barrière cette barrière
pour masquer notre incompétence à
organiser le service public que veut
dire le service public que nous disent
toutes les jurisprudences des magistrats
c'est que la personne qui sait ce qu'est
le degré d'urgence c'est l'usagé du
service public le patient là de mettre
ce filtre c'est ridicule et c'est bien
l'italie entre les mailles des filets il
est là je
comprends ce que veulent faire les
collègues par désespoir d'organisation
qui ne fonctionne plus entre la ville
l'hôpital entre l'hôpital et laval mais
faut pas empêcher les gens de venir aux
urgences il va cesser c'est
contradictoire avec la mission de
service public et notre travail
humaniste d'accueillir les personnes qu
après alors c'est vrai nous sommes dans
un chaos total parce que notamment on
n'a pas valorisé l'oublié du ségur vous
savez c'est 65 % du temps de travail de
l'hôpital c'est la permanence de soins
on n'a pas valorisé la permanence de
soins ce qui fait que vous avez une
c'est le travail de la nuit le travail
le week-end conditions de travail les
jours fériés c'est tout ce travail là on
croit que c'est une parenthèse non la
société a évolué l'hôpital est resté au
milieu du xxème siècle l'hôpital croit
toujours que 100% des français partent
en vacances l'été c'est faux il y en a
même pas 30 % maintenant d'accord et il
croit toujours que les jambes à la nuit
ils vont d'hommes non la ville bouge la
société bouge ce qui fait que l'hôpital
est en retard d'à peu près une
cinquantaine d'années sur le mode de
fonctionnement de la société on comprend
que voilà vous dites la catastrophe est
déjà là l'hôpital va craquer d'autant
qu'elle était avec l'afflux des
touristes on est déjà imaginé chaque
année à cette époque puisque vouliez
parler l'assistance publique c'est les
chiffres qui ont été données par le
directeur général d'assistance publique
normalement on est à 5% de fermetures de
lits ce qui correspond aux chambres de
malades qu on repeint les lélés les
bricolages xterra tout ça là on est à
14% déjà de fermetures de lits donc ce
qui vous voulez cet été on est sûr parce
qu'il va falloir donner les congés au
personnel parce que personne si vous
n'avez pas les congés ils se tirent donc
voilà donc d'un coup il faut leur donner
congé donc on va arriver à 20 25 % on
vient déjà de fermer un hôpital qui
s'appelle la collégiale qui assurait le
soin de suite et des prises en charge
notamment des personnes âgées mais c'est
un drame absolu pour légumes alors
évidemment on comprend la pénurie de
personnel de toutes façons ces gens là
ont été essorés par le cos vide il était
déjà largement démobiliser avant
dans quel état d'esprit sont ceux qui
restent ceux qui n'ont pas encore
raccroché de loi c burn out c'est quoi
c'est quoi elle est à nuancer c'est pire
que ça ça s'appelle le grand renoncement
vous avez eu des tas d'articles ont été
faits aux etats unis c'est le grand
renoncement sans doute vous avez raison
une conséquence de la crise du coc vide
et là on est désabusé c'est à dire qu'on
se dit on y arrivera plus quelque part
l'identifiant est l'objet
fédérateur du service public et de
l'hôpital public n'est plus ce qui fait
que là on se dit bon bah voilà j'ai des
collègues qui disent brougham watts sont
je m'engage plus dans le service public
là pour la première fois de son histoire
à l'assistance publique il ya dix postes
de praticiens hospitaliers c'est-à-dire
de titulaire en chirurgie orthopédique
qui nous même pas été pourvu il n'y a
même pas de demande c'est vous dire la
déliquescence de l'intérêt parmi les
médecins pour la chose publique et tous
les hôpitaux sont concernés petite
taille quand on va à bordeaux marseille
vous pouvez parler aussi d'oléron où
d'un coup l'autre jour on nous dit on va
fermer la structure d'urgence sur l'île
d'oléron c'est dramatique et ce qu'est
la structure d'urgence et a très peu
d'urgentistes parfois jusqu'à 2 3%
malades qui arrivent sans patient après
il ya les étages il ya là même signalé
il ya les médecins et là aussi c'est la
pénurie du coup on peut arriver aux
urgences mais ne pas être hospitalisé
pareil et c'est la même chose en
psychiatrie et c'est la même chose en
pédopsychiatrie c'est la même chose on a
6 tu as enfin on est dans le mur et le
château s'est effondré alors vous avez
une proposition d'urgence c'est pas la
réforme qu'il faudrait fermer tout de
suite là maintenant vous dites il faut
réintégrer les soignants non vaccinés
oui à l'hôpital mais pourquoi fais pas
ça changerait vraiment la donne écoutez
d'abord un voile à la crise est passée
faut savoir passer l'épongé etc et puis
surtout ça ferait quelques milliers de
personnes qui reviendrait travailler à
l'hôpital c'est quand même utile puisque
nous sommes en crise et des ah ça c'est
déjà ça ça c'est la première mesure
deuxième mesure faut valoriser de
manière très urgente le travail de nuit
restant un instant sur les non-vaccinés
parce que vous avez un peu ferrailler
dans le parisien avec menaces d'un
groupe qui vous dira mais attention
d'abord il ya encore 30 mai de 15 jours
de coded mais ensuite il ya une ambiance
anti vaccins qui a gagné l'hôpital non
si vous si vous donnez ils sont la
présence ou non vacciner des gens qui ne
croit pas à la science c'est qu'il
aurait gagné il faut qu'on que vous me
répondez vous aux jeux il faut
comprendre pourquoi des soignants et des
gens qui travaillent dans l'hôpital qui
est vraiment la quintessence de la
connaissance actuelle de la science sont
en opposition avec la science parce que
si son compte le vaccin bientôt ils vont
être content la chimiothérapie puis
contre les antibiotiques à le comprendre
les réintégrant dans l'hôpital il faut
les réintégrer comprendre je pense que
c'est tout l'intérêt peut être un
travail des anthropologues des
sociologues pour comprendre pourquoi il
faut les réintégrer parce que là
l'urgence est de prendre en charge les
malades c'est pas d'avoir une
surmortalité manuel mac où il avait
ouvert la porte
à cette possibilité de réintégration de
région et fin avril mais la ministre de
la santé toujours en place olivier
ferrand a l'air de dire pas question
pour le nord mais s'il doit trancher
cette question là ras de sol pourrait
renforcer les on enlève les masques et
puis après il dit ce mot love sait si
c'est complètement contradictoire bon on
voulait masquer
fallait garder il fallait garder les nas
dans les transports c'est une erreur
mais si vous voulez là il ce qui est sûr
c'est que l'épidémie n'est pas terminée
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que la nu de
la crise que nous avons là et
l'effondrement de l'hôpital public
nécessite des mesures d'urgence et on
peut pas laisser plusieurs milliers de
personnels à l'écart voilà c'est ça
alors les quelques milliers de deux
soignants non vaccinés ne vont pas
résoudre évidemment d'un coup d'un seul
la crise il ya eu le fait qu arrive
qu'on va rouvrir le plu de l'île de ly
que l'on va rouvrir c'est déjà ça je
vous assure qu'en vous passer la nuit
sur un brancard sous un drap à moitié à
poil en attendant ali dans la souffrance
et la douleur c'est pas possible et
notamment penser à ce qu'ils peuvent pas
s'exprimer les handicapés les personnes
âgées pour la réforme que vous attendez
on sait qu'à la fin du numerus clausus
mais ça prend du temps on sait que le
gouvernement a déjà mis en place des
pôles de santé dans les territoires pour
éviter d'aller vers l'hôpital ça marche
pas les 183 euros de primes mensuelles
c15 fusion c'est insuffisant il sait il
faut les intégrer toutes ces primes
fusil intégré en salaire pas grand chose
vous savez c'est que c'est comme ça
voilà c'est la voiture qui est en panne
vous continuez à la pousser dans la côte
mais elle va pas redémarré s'il n'y a
pas d'essence voilà alors qu'est ce que
vous proposez bah il faut un big bang
sur le système de santé sur les valeurs
du service public
d'accord faut changer d'équipé c'est à
dire en fait d'interlocuteurs donc là
c'est bien on va changer de ministre
donc ça c'est sa voix la changer ne sait
pas qu'il est nous l'avons errants et
met sur sa vous avez des informations
vous poserez verrou marquée par la crise
je pose plus faux des balles neuves faut
des balles neuves n'ont pas en accusant
ce qu'ils étaient
là mais moi j'ai vu passer tant et tant
de ministres et c est toujours les mêmes
petite musique qui sont il faut changer
j'ai pas non j'ai moi je veux quelqu'un
qui le mettent autour de la table en
disant écoutez voilà on valorise la
permanence de soins on augmente la
rémunération des gens qui travaillent la
nuit et les week-ends que ce soit les
infirmières d'ailleurs tout le monde
d'accord qu'on ait les mêmes conditions
de défiscalisation que ce qu'ont les
médecins libéraux puisque quand ils font
de la permanence de soins nuit ils ont
soixante jours défiscaliser c'est quand
même pas rien qu'on réorganise l'hôpital
en lui même mais baby vie alors alors
comment remettre démocratie la tentative
à l'administration n'ont rien à voir non
non vous savez il ya autant de cons d'un
côté deux autres d'accord donc ça rien à
voir c'est juste des méthodes c'est à
dire quand vous voyez moi je parle
souvent avec des grands chefs
d'entreprise je suis passionné par le
management qu'ils ont de proximité avec
des valeurs de bienveillance et cd4 nous
l'hôpital on est resté au 20e siècle et
vous avez l'impression que généralement
les chefs de service sont recrutés chez
les narcissique pervers donc c'est pas
possible faut changer ça faut écouter
faut écouter que ce soit la femme de
ménage
l'aide soignante l'ambulancier faut donc
faire naître alors on a plein d'outils
déjà mais on les a jamais mis en place
les conseils de service n'en sait pas
que des moyens mais des moyens mais
aussi une globalité une façon d derrière
ça est derrière ça il faut augmenter les
salaires parce que quand on est encore à
la 18e place des pays dos et des oeufs
pour les personnels les infirmières
notamment c'est pas possible c'est pas
possible il ya et si vous voulez je
prends cette gouvernement là pour faire
tout ça by ap ap l'hôpital on en a marre
les dans la campagne mais non royer
vraiment noah dont la frappe à gijon ce
problème cette crise la rue ils en ont
pas parlé ils ont fait le débat avec
marine le pen il on nous parle
exactement une minute une minute après
une crise sans précédent
d'accord avec des risques absolument
majeur sur la crise parce que la crise
qui est en train d'arriver avec
l'inflation les augmentations de prix
etc on sait que ça va augmenter la
pauvreté c'est des gens qu'on va
retrouver à l'hôpital public bon mais
l'hôpital public s'y tient pas vous avez
une société profondément inhumaine et
donc violente et donc la société crée sa
propre violence voyez parce que moi je
conte quand les gens quand ils arrivent
aux urgences et qu'ils attendent ils
viennent d'en d'urgence il estime que
c'est urgent il faut comprendre même le
médecin va dire c'est pas urgent des u10
que c'est urgent et ils vont avoir un
retard de prise en charge au mec bien on
vous entend on entend les alertes et
puis les premiers jalons que que vous
posez on voudrait invitera pour parler
de la réforme puisque on a pour
l'instant rien sur rien sur la table pas
même le nouveau gouvernement propose de
rester avec moi c'est l'heure
d'accueillir nos a franchi pour leur
parti pris ce soir eh bien on va
retrouvé l amour d'un gars va décidément
très présent dans cette émission pour
son carnet de campagne des législatives
à brandon ouaret il va nous parler de
des surprises c'est la clé d'un
remaniement réussi et puma accueillir un
nouveau visage dans cette émission
chloride elle militante engagée pour
l'écologie et la démocratie elle va nous
parler d'un rapport important celui de
lens est la revue scientifique the
lancet pts sur la pollution nos a
franchi les voici bonsoir à tous les
trois malheureusement patrick peloux m'a
glissé à l'instinct qu' il n'avait pas
le temps de rester avec nous mais ce
n'était pas longvic qui lui manquaient
on va commencer avec damien abad enfin
avec vous lda vous on a beaucoup parlé
danube que ce soir on a parlé de de ce
remaniement que l'on attend il ya une
info qui est tombée c'est damien abad le
président du groupe des républicains à
l'assemblée qui quitte ses fonctions
sous la pression des républicains sa
famille politique exactement alors il
reste de droite il le dit mais il a
annoncé effectivement dans le figaro
c'est autour de 19h il quitte la
présidence du groupe ici à l'assemblée
il se met aussi en retrait de son parti
pourquoi et bien parce que damien abad
il a dû répondre à un ultimatum de son
camp qui le soupçonne de vouloir
franchir le rubicon et de rejoindre
emmanuel macron alors il faut dire qu
emmanuel hab que damien abad pardon il
n'a pas attendu longtemps le soir du
premier tour pour annoncer qu'il
voterait emmanuel macron il a adressé
ses félicitations au chef de l'état le
soir de sa réélection et on le sait
maintenant de manière certaine depuis
plusieurs jours la majorité n'a pas
investi de candidat face à lui pour le
remercier de cette posture de
responsabilité et de clarté mardi il ya
eu une réunion de groupe ici à
l'assemblée le président à badens peut
esquiver les leaf au milieu de la pièce
sauf que et bien coût de député le
rendement 10 en termes plus ou moins
polie de choisir son camp il a demandé à
48 heures pour réfléchir fin de
l'ultimatum cet après midi christian
jacob le président du parti a publié un
communiqué avec des termes peu amènes il
lui a dit qu'il ne pouvait pas attendre
le bon vouloir de monsieur macron de le
prendre ou de ne pas le prendre dans le
gouvernement et qu'ils devaient dès à
présent quitté ses fonctions alors
pourquoi pourquoi damien abad a voulu
gagner du temps alors sa version c'est
qu'il faut évidemment du temps pour
faire ce choix c'est compliqué les
mauvaises langues diront bien qu'il
attendait le remaniement le nouveau
gouvernement de savoir si l'entrée ou
pas lui jure qu'il n'a négocié aucun
poste et puis l'attendais aussi selon
des mauvaises langues toujours et bien
la date limite qui est demain de dépôt
des gardes candidature pour s'assurer
que son parti allait investir personnes
face à lui fait une surprise à oopa ce
départ des républicains nouveau
débauchage n'ont pas forcément alors
débauchage pour l'instant on sait pas
trop ce qui rejoint en voisin et quitte
la droite sait pas trop où il atterrit
c'est pas vraiment une surprise damien
abad c'est un nom qu'on entend déjà
quand il ya eu des remaniements il ya
quelques années lui a toujours refusé
mais moins par intérêt par sur le fond
politique mais parce qu'il savait que le
symbole de sa dette président de groupe
était trop important il n'a pas voulu
lâcher ses troupes donc c'est pas
franchement une surprise mais maintenant
faut savoir est ce qui rentre dans
l'équipe gouvernementale
ou est ce que finalement il reste
chez nous on a compris que c'est une
question de jours moi pas dire d'armes
et de mes deux jours merci beaucoup
merci elle d'un carnet de campagne
quotidien dans cette émission sur les
législatives alors brandon avec vous
brandon ouaret bonsoir on va parler des
remaniements mais de ceux qui ont marqué
notre histoire la clé d'un bon
remaniement ce sont les surprises et il
y en a eu pas mal dans le passé il y en
ait beaucoup effectivement est la
première grande surprise on la doit au
général de gaulle qui pour son premier
gouvernement en 1944 choisir un simple
paysan pour diriger l'agriculture par
cette nomination de gaulle souhaite
rendre hommage aux paysans de la france
résistante or cette surprise du chef qui
a pris cours au cap les deux cours aussi
bien les politiques que la presse
s'appelle tanguy prigent et en
débarquant à paris vous allez l'entendre
il apporte aussi dans ses valises la
fraîcheur de sa bretagne natale
vaillant les amis produisent en
nourrissant nos frères il s'agit
d'éviter la famille d'un autre pays de
sauver les petits de préparer une
jeunesse afin d'assurer une population
robuste ce pur produit de la
méritocratie républicaine - fermiers
sans étude va quand même conservé son
ministère durant six gouvernements c'est
assez exceptionnel c'est exceptionnel et
c'est beaucoup trop rare je dirais
encore aujourd'hui en 1992 autre
surprise complètement autre profil le
premier ministre pierre bérégovoy n'a
pas d'autre choix à la surprise générale
de nommer le nouveau poulain du
président mitterrand 1 c'est bernard
tapie qui devient ministre de la ville
c'est d'ailleurs un ministère créé de
toutes pièces spécialement pour lui
alors c'est le nouveau missile politique
du président qui avait quand même réussi
à se faire élire c'est un exploit député
des bouches du rhône en 1988 dans un
bastion de droite réputée imprenable
pour la gauche imposée par mitterrand il
a justement cette étiquette assez
luxueuse quand même ce nouveau ministre
est bien consciente dans la majorité on
ne partage pas du tout sa nomination et
on est assez jaloux et il en est bien
conscient écouter le suis pas habitué
encore mais ça va venir les peaux de
banane vont être nombreuses il faudra
qu'on résiste et je pas qu'autour de
bérégovoy il ya des gens qui sont prêts
à résister à toutes les attaques à une
peau de banane ça va mais quand c'est le
bananier qu'on vous êtes en plein visage
c'est plus difficile de résister un mois
et demi plus tard écoutez le
si j'étais condamné c'est à dire si on
me donnait tort à ce moment là c'est ma
morale d'hommes qui est en cause
même si ça n'a rien à voir avec des
fonds publics je ne resterai pas parce
qu'on peut pas être mise en cause sur sa
morale être un des représentants dans
une tâche les plus noble qui soit pour
un homme politique c'est à dire avoir
une tâche ministériels et le lendemain
bernard tapie mise en examen pour abus
de biens sociaux est contraint de
démissionner blanchi par en haut lieu il
réintégrera le gouvernement six mois
plus tard au mois de mai au mois de
décembre 1992 jusqu'à ces fameuses
législatives de 1993 là où le parti
socialiste restera au tapis tirait plus
d'aller retour sains comme ça une
procédure où vous restez vous partez
mais alors partir pour revenir à presser
c'est plus rapidement la surprise elle
peut aussi prendre des allures de coup
politique et nicolas sarkozy en est
effrayant on avait déjà eu l'épisode
socialiste bernard kouchner a nommé au
ministère des affaires étrangères en
2007 et deux ans plus tard la droite
récidive en 2009 c'est un coup de
théâtre françois fillon nomme un tout
nouveau en politique c'est frédéric
mitterrand le neveu de l'ancien
président comme nouveau ministre de la
culture et l'émotion elle est tellement
forte pour le nouveau ministre qu'il se
précipite pour annoncé lui même sa
nomination au grand dam du protocole
officiel qu'est ce que ça représente
personnellement pour vous
une tâche exaltante et un honneur un
mitterrand ministre du gouvernement
sarkozy c'est assez étonnant
sarkozy a bien été ministre au temps de
mitterrand il oublie quand même de
préciser que certains nicolas sarkozy a
été ministre au temps de mitterrand mais
il était ministre du budget sous le
gouvernement balladur en pleine
cohabitation ce n'est plus du tout la
même chose il est finalement cela lui a
pas coûté il est quand même mais était
quand même nommé ministre à bombay merci
beaucoup et grand plaisir merci à
brandon on attend évidemment la surprise
où les surprises du chef macron une idée
rachel kahn à la culture qui nous baser
qu'elle est chez nous hier à la dic avec
ça il ya énormément de liste qui
circulent ici des listes
ultraconfidentiels
vraiment mais non je pense qu'on saura
demain après demain ou lundi ou moins
patients bonsoir que héridel soient
ravis de vous accueillir pour vous
situer un peu vous vous êtes la
directrice adjointe de l'institut
rousseau plutôt en pointe sur les
questions écologiques mais aussi sur les
questions démocratiques et puis vous
avez une association mieux voter on vous
avait reçu ici même et on vous accueille
parmi nos a franchi pour nous parler ce
soir du rapport de cette revue
scientifique au combien respecter
delande 7 sur la pollution liée aux
activités humaines qui tuent nous dit ce
rapport 9 millions de personnes chaque
année oui les polluants de l'air de
l'eau des sols sont responsables d'un
décès sur six dans le monde 9 millions
de morts par an c'est autant que ce que
provoque le sida la tuberculose et le
paludisme réunis donc ce que cette étude
nous dit c'est que nous vivons dans un
monde de pollution et que cette
pollution tue partout en lisant cette
étude j'ai ressenti une bien triste
ironie parce que je me suis rappelé
qu'il y a dix ans
l'onu se réjouissait que l'objectif
numéro un du millénium pour le
développement à savoir faire reculer
l'extrême pauvreté dans le monde avait
été atteint avec une rapidité étonnante
et à l'époque on répétait beaucoup que
le capitalisme mondialisé avait réussi à
faire reculer cette pauvreté au pas de
course et c'est incontestable puisque
par exemple en asie la pauvreté extrême
c'était 77% des populations à la fin des
années 90 et c'est 14% dans les années
2010 sauf que ces progrès ce recul de la
pauvreté a été obtenue auprès d'une
pollution au prix d'une pollution
généralisée on constate aujourd'hui
puisque la mondialisation a certes
permis aux pays émergents de croître
très vite et très fort mais cette
croissance a reposé sur des usines ultra
polluantes des navires poubelles des
conditions de travail précaires et du
coup en asie et en afrique la mort a
pris un autre visage puisque les décès
liés à l'extrême pauvreté ont reculé
mais ils ont été comme remplacés par des
décès liés à la pollution de l'air des
sols de l'eau et je crois que ce constat
suffit à montrer l'impasse d'un modèle
de développement qui a remplacé un
problème par un autre nous avons certes
réduit la pauvreté éradiquer certaines
maladies féroce mais ces progrès sont
aujourd'hui annulée par l'augmentation
des pollutions qui sème des morts
nouvelle alors quand l'onu déjà se
réjouissait de cet objectif vous avez
parlé pour le développement cet objectif
avait été atteint avec cinq ans d'avancé
ils auraient dû voir d'une certaine
façon la chute supercherie et ce progrès
qui se retourne aujourd'hui contre
l'être humain contre la nature qui n'en
était pas un non je ne crois pas parce
que pour parler de progrès il faudrait
réussir à construire un monde où nous
parviendrions à éradiquer la pauvreté
tout en ne tuant pas le vivant et dans
cette étude du lent de cette les
scientifiques déplorent que nous ne
fassions pas assez pour lutter contre la
pollution et ils appellent même à la
création d'un giec donc un groupe
d'experts spécifiquement sur la question
des pollutions pour mieux les
répertorier parce que le pire dans tout
ça c'est que nous ne savons même plus
identifier les pollutions que nous avons
nous même engendré ni leurs conséquences
sur notre santé et en parlant de 9
millions de morts par an peut-être que
le land 7 sous-estiment les impacts
meurtrier dépollution chaque année nous
apprenons que telle ou telle substance
contenue dans tel ou tel produit de
grande consommation les couches pour
bébé les tétines le maquillage les
écrans d'ordinateur nous expose à des
dangers dont on ignorait jusque alors
l'existence et puis il n'ya pas que les
pollutions physique il ya aussi les
pollutions sonores des pollutions
lumineuses qui ont aussi des
conséquences sur notre santé donc cette
société de pollution plus une société du
risque pour reprendre le terme du
sociologue ulrich beck c'est une société
de l'incertitude et si le risque peut
être maîtrisée l'incertitude elle rend
esclave c'est pourquoi je crois que
l'écologie notre unique chemin vers la
liberté ben voilà qui est dit un petit
petite note d'espoir quand même parce
que 9 millions à la de personnes chaque
année tu est due à cette pollution à
l'aller lui à nous en fait il ya
d'activité humaine c'est vertigineux
merci merci que les ridelles merci les
affranchis a très vite à très bientôt
nous deux ans parce qu'on va suivre ça
de près ce remaniement qui se fait
attendre très belle soirée documentaire
avec jean pierre graff y en a près dans
est admis
[Musique]